Speaker 1: Let's go to Markus from is
it Manitoba or Matt Manitoba? Yeah.
Marcus from Manitoba. Welcome to the program, sir.
Speaker 3: Yes. Yes, it is from Manitoba. In fact.
What's on your mind? I'm coming to you with.
Yeah. Yeah. And I'm coming to you with tears
in my eyes over this latest news from Fox News
that their star, Tucker Carlson, has been
booted here. And I'm wondering just how.
It got to the point where this guy is was
just sort of being given the platform to.
To some of like the most extreme and even within
like the circles of American conservatism.
Quite unpopular things, seemingly
just without any reprimand from
the organization he was working for.
Speaker 1: You're saying how did how
was Tucker able to say the things he
said without being reprimanded by Fox?
Speaker 3: I guess I'm just wondering,
like. How did Fox News not realize that
the things that Tucker Carlson, as well
as, you know, their other hosts for saying
are going to get them sued eventually?
Speaker 1: Well, it's more complicated
than that because most of the trouble that
Tucker caused for Fox is not really related
to the things he said. Yes, he played coy
with the Dominion and 2020 election stuff,
and that was part of the lawsuit. But it was less
about what Tucker himself was necessarily saying.
The lawsuit for discrimination from a staffer,
former staffer doesn't relate to what Tucker
said on air. The potentially forthcoming lawsuit
from Ray Epps would, but we'll have to wait and
see whether that's filed. So I think it's a little
more complicated than that. I mean, Fox's primary
concern is ratings, and Tucker had good ratings.
So that's fundamentally the most important thing.
Speaker 3: I guess so. Yeah, that's true.
But I suppose more broadly, I. I'm just
kind of wondering, like who. Tucker Carlson's
audience is apparently has a huge audience.
Um, but like, the things you were saying,
especially about, like, Russia and Ukraine. Like,
it's not something that like any of the other,
like, mainstream. Well, certainly not mainstream
Republicans, but even. It's not like it's the
he's taking the Russian position. He has said
that he is like pro-Putin, essentially.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he didn't say that,
but he certainly made some strange comments
about his audiences is right wingers. And there
is a desire for this contrarian sort of MAGA style
right wing ism, which often ends up using populist
rhetoric and being a little more deferential to
global authoritarians than you might think. So in
that sense, it's not that out of left field.
Speaker 3: I guess so. One of my favorite
sort of tropes that you see on the very far right,
you know, among people like like Matt Yates and
such, and which he kind of was demonstrated in
that one meeting of him. And that was that
one clip where he used Chinese propaganda
as evidence that the U.S. was funding the Aizawl
battalion in Ukraine, not realizing that it was
Chinese propaganda. And then it was embarrassed
when he was because like when it was shown to
him that it was Chinese propaganda.
Speaker 1: Yes. That absolutely that
absolutely did happen. But that that's
a bit of a different topic. Marcus,
thank you so much for the call. A move to move
on because I've got a bunch of people waiting,
but you certainly covered a gamut of issues, and
I really do. I really do appreciate that. Let's
go to and from Sweden and welcome to The David
Pakman Show. What's on your mind today? And please
unmute yourself, Andy, so that we can hear you.
Speaker 3: Hello, David. Can you hear me? Yes,
I can. I'm a big fan from Sweden and I have a
question to you in two parts if she's okay. Yeah,
of course. Who is your favorite chess player?
Speaker 1: I, I don't have a favorite chess
player. I. I'd have to. I don't
know. I don't think I have just one.
I don't think I have any, honestly.
Speaker 3: Are you watching the
world Championship?
Speaker 1: I have not.
I have not. I've been so busy. What's
going on? Is anything notable happening?
Speaker 3: I mean, it's very tired. Very
tired right now between Nepomniachtchi
from Russia and Dingli round from China.
Speaker 1: Okay, I'll try to I'll try to
follow a little bit if I can.
Speaker 3: And so you can watch
on Chess.com. They have a stream right now.
Beautiful. And the second part. So who do you
think is the best chess player in Washington in
terms of, you know, in Congress and in the Senate?
Speaker 1: I have absolutely no
idea. Do any of them even play chess?
Speaker 3: I have no idea. Maybe they play for us.
Speaker 1: Right. Right. Okay. Thank you, Andy
from Sweden. Thank you. I very much appreciate
that. Let's end there and not press our luck. We
will take calls again and we will do so next week.
We will take a break and be back right after this.